andrew cruz says
where do you draw the line between
compromise and just giving the girl what
she wants or is compromising not really
a thing we should be doing
uh you know what i'm going to rely on to
respond to this is going to be
16 commandments let's just pull it up
because i'll just i'll just cite it
verbatim
but one of them is on
i think it's number four don't play by
her rules
actually let me cover four and five let
me cover four and five so let's put this
up here for you because this is
this is something that's bound to come
up let me share the screen here
standby brothers there we go
put it up over here it's a little bit
better that way if you allow a woman to
make the rule she will resent you with a
seething contempt even a rapist cannot
inspire
the strongest woman and the most
strident feminist wants to be led by and
to submit to
a more powerful man guys it doesn't
matter
how much toxic feminism bangs
into women's head the narrative
women still want to be led by and
protected by a more powerful man they
always do
a more powerful man is a key word here
polarity is the core of a healthy loving
relationship she does not want the
prerogative to walk all over you
with her capricious demands and mercial
moods
her emotions are a hurricane her soul a
saboteur
think of yourself as a bulwark against
her tempest when she gasps for a pillar
to steady herself against
the whipping winds or yearns for an
authority figure to foil her worst
instincts
i love how this guy writes it is you has
to be there strong solid unshakable
and immovable let's talk about the
golden ratio because this kind of comes
to andrew's point
you give your woman two-thirds of
everything that everything that she
gives you
right for every three calls or texts
give her two back three declarations of
love earn two
in return three gifts two nights out
take her two displays of
of affection stop until she's answered
with a third when she speaks you reply
with fewer words when she emotes you
emote less
the idea behind the golden ratio is
twofold establishes your greater value
by making her chase you
and it demonstrates to you that you have
the self-restraint to avoid getting
swept up in her personal dramas
see the problem guys is most of you have
been conditioned your entire life like
the good little blue pill plebs that
you're supposed to be to bend the knee
and to equal to become less so that she
can become more and she doesn't want
that
refraining from reciprocating everything
she does for you in equal measure
instills in her the proper attitude of
belief
in your higher status and her deepest
lines this is what she truly wants
women want to be with a giant guys they
do not want to be
with somebody that they deem lesser
value than them
you will end up with problems in a
long-term relationship or a marriage
if women look down at you if they speak
disparagingly to you
if they start making rules for example
around
the relationship and especially if they
start making rules around intimacy like
like chore play like oh i need you to do
this that and the other thing before
we're gonna have some basic missionary
starfish sex right
once that starts to happen you're
completely losing the frame and falling
into beta tization through a thousand
concessions
you gotta learn to say no it's a
complete sentence just say no
and as difficult as it sounds the burden
of performance is on men
right men must become you must do the
work you must pursue
excellence right it's it's it's expected
of you
as a man but not for women i keep have
to i feel like i have to emphasize this
so much is
you do it for you you do it so you have
options you do
so that you're the best version of
yourself so that if a
crummy woman or person business partner
customer comes into your life and you're
spoiled for choice and you don't want to
deal with them because they're an
anchor because they're an energy vampire
you can basically tell them to [ __ ] off
right that's really the entire point of
it is to have those options
but far too many guys have far few
options
you know because she smells pretty
oh she let me touch her boobie so i
married her
you